hallo zusammen herzlich willkommen zum
Q&A zu unserem Film FIFA schickt Fußball
WM 2022 in die Wüste Katas Kampf für ein
modernes Image es sind ziemlich viel
Fragen und Reaktionen auf der Film ihnen
Produzent vom Film und ich mir war jetzt
der es war von denen intensiver
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oder nicht ich persönlich finde es gibt
gute Gründe
wieso eine WMS boykottieren
aber ich finde es gibt kein spezifischen
Grund warum die wir im katastriere also
man muss sich einfach fragen warum denn
wir werden im speziell wenn man seit
Jahren
okay sie sind 94 alle WMS kauft wurde
die Bedeutung
ja nackte Mannschaft Situationen
ja die ist
nicht Frieden oder genügt eine Standard
aber zum Beispiel eine international
also Menschenrechtsorganisation seit das
ist wahrscheinlich die einzige WM ever
muss wo positive Auswirkungen haben will
sie eben genau in dem Bereich mega viel
handtöne erreiche und was wahrscheinlich
Zeitpunkt
sind
die international stürzt oder dass man
sagt hey
benutzte
organisiert worden ist und und nutze
jetzt die Aufmerksamkeit verbessern und
ich finde die grundsätzliche
handelt noch wertvoll sind
okay aber wo sie ganz Wirtschaft ist so
einfach verknüpft mit der katholischen
der habe kreiste
energiesicherheiten Herz Stelle oder
auch so ein verflochten mit unseren
Wirtschaft auch mit unserem Fußball der
wichtigsten
europäischen Fussball der Präsident von
PSG der uefox
der Jugendfreund vom Emir und wegen dem
boykottiert Champions League also man
muss sich hier den bewusst Sie dass das
mir so einfach verflochten sind und wenn
er wieder boykottieren müssen
oder halt wirklich sagen
wenigstens mit uns in der Mitte wegen
Gutachten
genau es sehen empfehlen wo auch immer
wieder zu Rede garheit ist die Szene
ganz am Schluss eigentlich wo man auf
der Baustelle gesehen mit dem
Bauinspektor mit dem Robert Schwitter
und mit durch Ritas chiavi und gerade
beim bauinspekt da hätte doch ziemlich
früh rausgesagt in der Kommentarspalte
vor allem geschrieben
die Bilder der Kantine der Unterkünfte
Schlafräumen und so weiter kommen mir
persönlich sehr seltsam rüber
okay
genau
kein Grund zum oder klar wird die Zeit
Zwiebel auf dem Herr
Schweizer Experte für genau daraus er
hat genau die Situation auf deine
Baustelle
baustellenunterkunft für deine Missstand
durch deine Baustellen oder so wenn man
das halt im Fernsehen bis dato so
mitkriegt
bitte Licht überrascht und Übernahme
eigentlich das Bild zeichnet erwartet
haben also eigentlich eins vor total
fortschrittliche und ähm und und
neumodische Baustelle wo top Zustand
sind auf dem neuesten Stand
für mich eigentlich wie erklärt oder
noch 2017 auf die stadionbaustellen für
die Inspektionen zu dem alles in dir
natürlich das ist zwar nicht unüblich
die sind vorankündigt gesehen also man
hat wie gewusst dass man Hund und die
Baustelle die sind ja ab 2014 sind hier
genau hätten
wir bisschen Inspektionen angefangen hat
ja ordentlich Zeit um die ganze
Situation
[Musik]
auf die internationales reagiere und das
hat man offenbar gemacht und mit der
Erklärung kann ich denn direkt okay gut
und wieder spricht auch wirklich
niemandemie also Gewerkschaften sagen
genau
2017 kein Problem mit G es ist doch vor
allem um andere Baustelle lauter was
natürlich nicht weniger schlimm ist und
was der viel grössere Teil ist muss man
sagen auf der stadionbaustelle über 0,5%
für alle Gastarbeiter geschaffen in
Katar aber das Problem ist nicht bitte
Stadien 2017 und genau mehr zum Beispiel
auch noch andere quotes
gesehen
Schauspielerin
[Musik]
sind sind
sicherheitsabsturzsicherung
überall zwei karabinenhagen
ist wirklich braucht und so es wird
wirklich lebt dass ich aus der prüfen
und noch als Baustelle konnte Leonie
natürlich
keine Chance geben was nicht ist kann
noch werden ich verstehe das Problem
nicht
ja voll absolut legitim also
die Chance Teil wie es genutzt das ist
deine Verbesserung und so weiter nützt
das langfristige bis und Fußball soll
verbinden das finde ich spannender
Aspekt wenn man Zeit also
Fußball Tradition und so weiter Fußball
WMC die nächste Fußball WM
1994 sowie Hand in die Fußball Tradition
und was man vergisst im arabische rund
gibt es unglaublich viel Fußball Fans
also in Katarina Saudi Arabien Iran
Ägypten die Leute nur Premier League
Liga und so weiter wenn der muss Salah
spielt denn nur mit dir Ali und ich
glaube Fußball zumindest
geht mega und die Leute freuen sich also
zumindest
davon interessiert freut sich mega auf
die WM sind tut mir der arabische Ruhm
inkludieren und es ist wie verbindet
nicht auf global gesehen
denn der Micha geschrieben über 10 WMS
und GPS wieso ist es wieso ist es denn
beim Fußball so das Problem mit denen
simple oder Formel 1 ist es
offensichtlich egal finde ich ein guter
Punkt
einfach die Fußball WM Organisation
ganze
sportmasterplan
ja dass sie einfach schon seit 1993 dann
ist einfach ein anderer bringen und ja
man kann sich fragen
können so kritisch hallo für viele sind
auch stark oder irgendwie bis baut wurde
Infrastruktur es ist bitte Lichtquelle
mal das Thema XIV mit dem Marathon hat
für die Nacht gegangen ist und würde
viel Leute viel Sport
kollabiert sind
aber ja absolut legitime Punkt
wahnsinnig viel Fans hat und wahnsinnig
bewegt und entsprechend halt einfach
wahnsinnig viel Aufmerksamkeit auf sich
zieht und da ist einfach ein Interesse
vorhanden wurde zu führt dass die
internationale Aufmerksamkeit einfach
größer ist als bei anderen Sportarten
mit ihnen spielt aber es ist völlig
legitim sagen dass man bei jeder
Weltmeisterschaft eigentlich kritisch ja
völlig fährst zum Schluss noch spannend
was mir zwei aus dem Projekt
hey das ist ein mega mega verwerflich
alles und ist schlimm und für mich ich
kann jetzt schon viel differenziertere
Blick kann ich das Gefühl auf die WM auf
Katar auf FIFA muss ich ja auch
verändert hat und es ist für mich auch
vieles Aurach nachvollziehbar wurden
warum die Sachen so passiert sind und
viel spannend oder zum Beispiel auch
Perspektive von Katar warum wenn Sie das
was
wirklich der Sicherheitsaspekt das
wirklich sich bedroht fühlt durch ebenso
Arabien und Iran zwei riesige mächt und
Sie können sich nicht militärisch wäre
gegen die sondern mit Aufmerksamkeit
machen und Sport oder ebenso
sportalistisches Mittel dazu
vergleichen mit der Kuh weit wo der
anfangs 90er Jahre
vom Irak überfallen wurde ich
ausgelisches Emirat wo von einer
grossmachtlos gesehen und das hat sich
glaube mega ist katarische Gedächtnis
von der Aufmerksamkeit Strategie
und zwar Korruption oder es ist immer
berichtet worden
mindestens dass das
bis wahnsinnig spezifisch ist also das
hat er sich mit der
korrupte Machenschaften
und unserem Dock und in der Recherche
mit der australischen wirklich echt klar
war daher mein Herz also ich kann das
Spiel
Spiele oder und hätte wählen mitmachen
und und und die WM für sich oder für
sich Land holen
oder Fifa spielen und da müssen wir
wichtig dass wenn man mit dem Finger
nach katter zeigt denn muss man mit dem
Finger auch Offizieren
Reportagen und Hintergrund
denn abonniert doch am besten der Kanal